in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help some global image
crunchers bring their costs down using
pre-emptive VMs will we get their
performance out of this world stay tuned
to find out sky eye is a research
organization whose focused on the health
of the planet by processing digital
imagery from satellites they came to me
with a massive problem as a seed funded
startup they were having trouble keeping
their core hours down since processing a
petabyte of image data on a regular
basis was a huge undertaking and was a
lot of costs their system grabs
satellite imagery and pushes the image
information to cloud storage while
pushing the metadata to datastore for
retrieval later they also have a
notification system set up when images
are uploaded to the GCS bucket which
creates a pub/sub message containing
details about where to find the image
this pub/sub message is then pulled by
an auto scaling instance group which
grabs the image data store information
and starts processing the image data all
the results are pushed to bigquery where
they can search sort and analyze the
results now at this point we ran down
the list of topics we checked how the
instance groups were performing what
their start-up time looked like and the
performance of their nodes individually
turns out one of their engineers was a
fan of our video series so all the stuff
that we would normally recommend was
already fixed thanks for watching which
meant that they weren't doing anything
wrong they just had a ton of work and
needed to keep the cost down which is
why I pointed them on the direction of
pre-emptive VMs pre-emptive VMs are the
same as regular instances except for one
key difference compute engine might
terminate these instances if it requires
access to those resources for other
tasks which can happen at any time now I
know what you're thinking that sounds
mega disruptive but they have one upside
by not guaranteeing indefinite uptime
Google is able to offer pre-emptive VMs
at a substantial discount to normal
instances which means they may not be a
fit for all of your architecture but
there may be parts of your cloud
application which they are ideal for for
sky-eye converting over to pre-emptive
VMs was pretty simple it started by
flipping the pre-emptive flag in their
instance template and then they made
modifications to handle the pre-emptive
events see both
or a PV M can be shut down it has to
signal your instance ahead of time
giving your app time to respond and
clear local data before things get lost
for the design that sky I was doing this
was really simple since they were doing
a pub/sub stream they just didn't
acknowledge the receipt and let another
vm in the group pick up that work and do
it on their behalf sky I shifted over
and recently completed a massive
experiment using almost 30,000 CPUs to
process 1 petabyte of imagery in just 16
hours all using pre-emptive VMS and
saving some serious coin
to learn more about the perf details of
these buckets check out the article
linked in the description below and
don't forget to check out the rest of
our cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts